et pour en parler nous sommes avec
gaëtan marengo professeur
d'histoire-géographie membres des stylos
rouges bonjour gueuleton bingo merci
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
arte france une rentrée scolaire sous
tension comment appréhendez-vous le
retour des élèves en classe
bonjour madame eh bien écoutez une fois
n'est pas coutume nous avons encore
cette fois-ci l'impression de tout
improvisé nous avons appris hier dans le
parisien les l'application de ce nouveau
protocole il était à peu près 17 heures
en fin de journée et évidemment on a dû
se tenir au courant pour être prêt ce
matin un protocole sanitaire qui change
qui n'est pas
assez stricte selon vous
concrètement qu'est ce qui ne va pas
eh bien écoutez nous sommes
particulièrement étonné de voir que ce
protocole est allé j'ai alors eu le
variant omicron fait de plus en plus de
cas puisque actuellement pour les la
tranche d'âge des 6-10 ans nous en
sommes à mille cas pour 100000 personnes
donc c'est deux fois plus que le reste
de la population le conseil scientifique
prévoit par ailleurs qu' au mois de
janvier deux cent mille enseignants
seront concernés par une absence nous
pouvons que constater une fois de plus
le manque de préparation du gouvernement
et le fait qu' ils livrent toujours les
personnels les familles et les élèves un
petit peu dans une situation de tracas
centre alors nouveau protocole sanitaire
qui risque d'être un casse-tête pour les
parents puisqu'il y aura plusieurs
plusieurs tests à effectuer pour pour
les enfants s'ils sont qu'un contact ou
malades pour les adultes les enseignants
là aussi ça risque d'être compliqué
puisque si jamais
un professeur est malade il sera absent
donc on risque de voir beaucoup de
professeurs qui ne seront pas leur poste
pendant cette rentrée est ce que il est
assez de monde pour pour les remplacer
le problème c'est que il manque déjà des
professeurs puisque ce gouvernement
depuis ie 2017 a réduit les conditions
d'accès aux concours il y a de moins en
moins de personnes qui veulent rentrer
dans la profession c'est qu'elle est
beaucoup moins attirante et même je
lisais ce matin qu'en seine-et-marne de
l'inspectrice d'académie
déjà d'emblée déclaré qu'il manquait des
professeurs dans les écoles et qu'elle
allait faire appel notamment aux
retraités puisqu'elle ne trouve pas non
plus suffisamment de professeurs
contractuels pour pallier aux absences
donc la situation est déjà délicate
alors que la rentrée n'a même pas
commencé
évidemment les victimes de tout cela ce
seront les élèves qui n'auront pas
l'enseignement qu'ils sont en droit
d'attendre et évidemment les personnels
qui vont devoir jongler comme d'habitude
et pour assurer leurs missions qu'est ce
que vous réclamez au
gouvernement pour pouvoir exercer votre
métier dans de bonnes conditions ne pas
être voilà en danger vous aimez aussi
les élèves on a vu la question notamment
du port des masques
ffp2 qui revenait avec insistance ces
derniers jours esprit modèle par exemple
de rendre le masque ffp2 obligatoire
pour le corps enseignant des ges que le
ministère de l'enseignement vous fournit
des masques à l'école
ce qui est très important pour nous tous
membres de la communauté éducatif c'est
de se sentir protégé et force est de
constater que c'est loin d'être le cas
nous réclamons
évidemment la fourniture de masques ffp2
nous réclamons la présence de détecteurs
de co2 et nous réclament on est aussi la
présence de purificateurs d'air vous le
savez bien sûr l'éducation nationale
libre s'est fourni ses personnels en
masque mais ces masses que vous l'avez
eue
sont très mal ajustée l'espace et les
particules ne conviennent pas du tout le
ministre a déclaré hier qu'il ne
livrerait pas de masques ffp2 parce
qu'il est très difficile de faire court
avec de tels masques permettez moi d'en
douter parce que nous les utilisons déjà
depuis bien longtemps et puis en fait ce
que nous réclamons c'est toujours la
même chose ce sont les moyens de pouvoir
exercer dans des conditions sereines
mais à part ouvrir des fenêtres qui ne
s'ouvre parfois pas toujours force est
de constater que ministre a pas grand
chose à nous proposer
merci beaucoup en tout cas cajetan
marengo d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes professeur
d'histoire-géographie membres des stylos
rouges